welcome back to drew's news now with a
hundred percent more gwyneth paltrow
[Applause]
this is an apt-worthy title of you
okay the new series sex love and goop is
making headlines
i watched the first two episodes i did
oh i certainly did i savored every
moment i have a lot to discuss
i haven't seen
a show
go to these places once again
you have broken a mold you are
innovating and you are opening up
conversations i have not seen elsewhere
oh okay i'm so glad you watched it thank
you and i'm so glad you liked it and
we're so proud of the show because
as you say you know it's like sex is
almost a microcosm of of your life and
everything all that you know everything
sort of comes out there right like how
you feel about yourself how honest you
are with yourself about your sexuality
what resentments you might have you know
towards yourself or others in life or
your partner and i think it's such an
area that gets so sticky for people and
there's such a lack of language around
how to you know especially for my
generation as a woman like to really
be okay with their sexuality or examine
your sexuality we have these amazing
couples come forward so it was this
incredible opportunity to
not only explore how
sexuality
rears its head between people but also
to offer them
time with these unbelievable experts who
have dedicated their lives to helping
people and
you watch people go on this journey and
make so much progress and there's some
incredible surprises and it was just i'm
just really proud of the show and i'm so
proud of my team at goop for
you know finding all these people and
doing such a good job and
i think it's going to be fun for people
to watch and what i love about it is
it's like stuff you can do at home
right like
i was talking to
uh somebody the other day and she said
she kept pausing it was a producer on a
podcast i was doing and she said she
watched it with her husband
and she kept pausing it and they kept
being like wait a minute like i've never
thought about this or that or could we
have this conversation or could is there
anything that you want to try that we've
never done or
you know and also giving people a
framework to have a difficult
conversation so i just i thought it was
that was a pretty cool part of it
because everybody
something about the show i think will
resonate with almost everybody because
we're having
we're all dealing with these issues
right but the stuff we don't talk about
that it's kind of we don't know how to
talk about it and you're giving it a
platform and people are really tearing
down their walls was there anything that
shocked you by how brave these people
were
there's a lot i mean imagine being
sexually vulnerable on camera you know
that to me is like i could never as open
as i am
like i could never do that and there's a
woman whose trauma her particular trauma
has manifested in
one kind of sex being very painful for
her and there is some hands-on bodywork
to help her
as they say in the show release the
trauma you know out of the tissue if you
believe in that you know out of her
heart and mind like it's it's really
it's unbelievably powerful to see it's
and and and the effect that it has on
her relationship is just extraordinary
it's so touching
it's you know it's just
i don't see things being discussed in
this way and to
have a show that gives empathy
structure and tools
to opening ourselves up
honestly
i need this show i do you know i really
do and i really think this is going to
be a big game changer of a show because
i have never seen anything like it i
mean it i i this is this has not been on
television
oh thank you well done
well done as usual
[Applause]
[Music]